SPEAKER: Five, four,
three, two, one, fire.
NARRATOR: The Cold War saw a
lot of nuclear weapons testing,
by the US, Soviet Union,
UK, France, and others.
The US did much of
their early testing
at Bikini Atoll in
the South Pacific.
The Soviets chose a remote
part of what's now Kazakhstan.
The story of Bikini Atoll is
not a proud one for the US.
Local residents there
were shuffled inexpertly
around nearby islands
before the testing,
and many were still exposed to
dangerous levels of radiation.
But, as embarrassing as
that episode is for the US,
it's nothing compared to
what happened in Kazakhstan.
In 1949, the Soviet
Union detonated
their very first
atomic bomb in an area
called Semipalatinsk, known
locally as The Polygon.
The region was roughly
the size of New Jersey,
and according to one of
the programs architects
it was uninhabited.
As it turns out,
that claim was off
by about 1.5 million people.
It's hard to know whether the
Soviet military was simply
callous in its choice of test
site, or downright sinister.
There are reports of
villagers being instructed
to step outside their
homes before detonations so
that the effect of
radiation exposure
could later be studied.
Either way, for 40
years, from 1949 to 1989,
the Soviets detonated nuke
after nuke here, as many as 456
of them.
That's so many that the
explosions became almost
commonplace for some villagers.
Almost every day,
recalled one woman.
Announcements on the
radio at noon would say,
now there's going to be a
test of nuclear weapons.
Everything would shake.
The windows in my classroom
were shattered by the shock wave
from one of the blasts.
All these tests laid
waste to the environment.
Rivers and water sources
were contaminated,
farmland was tainted,
and the people
began to suffer
almost immediately.
Cancer rates skyrocketed,
as did mental disabilities,
infertility, depression,
and harrowing birth defects.
All in all, around
200,000 people
are believed to have suffered
directly from radiation.
The weapons testing
finally ceased
with the collapse of the
Soviet Union in 1989,
but the shadow cast by
the program remains long.
To this day 1 in 20 children
born in The Polygon area
suffer deformities.
The suicide rate is four
times the national average.
And then there's the fact
that when the site closed,
Russia essentially
just walked away,
leaving untold amounts of
radioactive material behind.
The towns in and
around The Polygon
were poor enough that scavenging
metal from the old facilities
became commonplace, further
subjecting locals to radiation.
The United States
caught wind of this
and launched a massive effort
with Russia and Kazakhstan
to secretly clean
up the test site.
A mission that wasn't
finished until 2012.
The moral of the story,
as if it needs one,
is that nuclear testing
can leave a mark
on a place for generations.
The residents of Bikini
Atoll still understand this,
and Kazakhstan understands
it maybe best of all.
So well in fact
that the country has
helped lead the charge to ratify
the comprehensive nuclear test
ban treaty.
The treaty calls for nothing
less than a worldwide end
to all nuclear detonations,
though it won't go into effect
until it's ratified by all 44 of
the key nations who created it.
Russia, notably, has
ratified the treaty, perhaps
with the memory of the
polygon fiasco still fresh.
And in fact today there are only
eight holdouts, China, Egypt,
Iran, Israel, India,
Pakistan, North
Korea, and the United States.
If you like this video, please
subscribe to this channel.
We're putting out new
stories from around the world
all the time.
And thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]